welcome everyone this screencast is an
overview of assignment 2 and its
Associated Bake Off the name of this
combination is few shot open QA with DSP
and part of the function of the
screencast is to unpack that complicated
sounding title
let's begin with a review of different
question answering tasks and keep in
mind that the task you're confronted
with for this assignment and Bake Off is
the one in the final row which is very
difficult indeed let's begin at the top
QA standard QA the way this is
formulated in the modern phase as in
data sets like Squad is that you're
given a gold evidence passage and the
name of the game is to train a QA reader
that will learn to find answers to
questions in those evidence passages and
in this mode we don't have a retriever
at all so I put n a here
we've talked about openqa this is the
variant where we're not given a passage
but rather we need to learn to retrieve
relevant passages and then in the
standard mode we train a QA module to
learn how to find answers to questions
in those retrieve passages and that is
already substantially harder because now
we have to retrieve good evidence and we
don't have a guarantee that the answer
will even be findable in the evidence
that we've retrieved
few shot QA is something we haven't
discussed yet this is the task that was
really introduced in the gpt3 paper and
it's hard along a different dimension in
this mode we are given a gold passage we
could use squad for example as the basis
for the task but we're not allowed to do
any task specific reader training we
have to rely on a Frozen large language
model to learn in context how to do what
we want it to do
and in this mode there's no retrieval
because we just rely on the closed
nature of a task like Squad
that's already hard enough because you
don't get to do any task specific
training
we're going to move you into a mode that
combines the hard aspects of open QA and
few shot QA and that is few shot open QA
in this mode
you do not have a gold evidence passage
and you are compelled to use only Frozen
language models to do the QA part
we're going to have a retrieval
mechanism for you you could do some fine
tuning of it but we're not going to
explore that in this homework that could
be left for projects so really in the
end what you're left with is a frozen
retrieval model a frozen language model
and on that basis you need to figure out
how to answer questions effectively just
to repeat your situation is a difficult
one
during development you will have gold QA
pairs
but at test time all you're going to
have is questions no gold passages or
any other Associated data you will see
this in the Bake Off file it is simply a
list of questions that you need to
figure out how to answer very difficult
indeed I feel like this task would not
even have been posable in 2018 and when
we first did it last year I worried that
it might be too difficult but people did
incredible things and I think you're
going to do incredible things with this
seemingly almost impossible task
but just to emphasize here you have to
operate throughout this with frozen
components you cannot train any llms all
you can do is in context learning with
frozen models but I assure you you'll
get traction on this problem
just as a reminder for that task that I
mentioned few shot QA that is the one
that was posed in the gpt3 paper here's
an example from their appendix it's a
squad example you can see you have this
gold passage that you prompt your
language model with
you give it a demonstration QA pair
and then you have your final Target
question the demonstration follows the
substring guarantee into the gold
evidence passage and so it is the answer
and that's how they pose this and they
did pretty well at it and just as a
check I tried text DaVinci 2 with
exactly this example and got the right
answer so no regression there they can
still do few shot QA with Squad with
these deployed models
but as I said that's not your task your
task is harder in your setting
you're just given a question and the
task is to answer it and a standard
Baseline in this mode is what I've
called retrieve then read and so the way
this would work is that you'll rely on a
retrieval mechanism to find a context
passage that's relevant for this
question
and then you might add in for few shot
retrieve then read some demonstrations
and you could get those from the squad
data set that we provide to you or you
could try to get it from somewhere else
you could also tr get from your train
set or retrieve an answer to that
demonstration question and the same
thing for the context Squad provides all
of these as gold evidence but it's
conceivable that you would want to
retrieve answers or predict answers and
retrieve passages so that your system
learns from demonstrations that are kind
of like the actual situation that you
have down here where there's no gold
passages and no gold answers just
questions and everything else has to be
found somewhere
for the assignment itself we're pushing
to use the demonstrate search predict
programming library and the vision
behind this library is that we're going
to make prompt engineering proper
software engineering where you write a
little program as opposed to typing out
a prompt from scratch and the idea here
is that that opens up a whole new design
space and really gets us thinking in new
ways about how to design AI systems in
this modern mode that are essentially
prompting Frozen pre-trained components
and getting them to work in concert to
do complicated things that we want done
so this is a diagram from the DSP paper
and you're going to be writing little
programs that look like this
for the notebook itself we begin with
some setup and what you see Happening
Here is that we're kind of connecting
with some large language model vendors
who provide powerful Frozen language
models that you can use here's the key
for open Ai and here's the one for
cohere these are not supplied to you so
you need to get set up separately with
your own API keys for cohere you can use
the models for free and for open AI when
you open an account you get some small
number of free credits to use for their
models
and then finally we set you up with a
Colbert server this is an index that we
created that will provide you with a
very rich retrieval mechanism
and then in the cell down here we set up
using the DSP Library the language model
here I'm using text DaVinci one and I've
got my open AI key associated with it
and there's the commented out version
for doing this with cohere models and
here I set up the retrieval mechanism
and the final piece here is to just set
DSP as a library so that you're using
that LM and that retrieval mechanism
so that's by way of setup
one thing I wanted to pause on here is
the appearance of squad in the notebook
that might surprise you because Squad is
a closed
standard QA formulation of the task
where you're given gold passages and so
forth so I want to emphasize that the
role of squad here is to provide you
with some training and Dev examples and
I put train in quotation marks there
because of course you can't train any
systems but you can use the train
portion of squad to construct
demonstrations for your passages and
other things like that
so in essence Squad is providing train
data gold QA pairs maybe with gold
passages that you'll make use of that
you can use for demonstrations and Squad
also provides Dev QA pairs that we can
use to simulate your actual situation so
that you can figure out how well your
system is going to do at test time that
is on the Bake Off
so that's why you get this section Squad
train Squad Dev Squad Dev sample that
final thing there is just because you
should keep in mind that in this mode
evaluations can be quite expensive
especially if you're paying open AI for
each one of its API calls and so you'll
want to do evaluations on small data
sets and do them only sparingly so I've
provided you with a tiny sample of 200
Dev examples to kind of use in a very
controlled way although honestly even
that can get quite expensive and so I
would do even those kind of quantitative
evaluations only sparingly
background in place we can begin
thinking about using DSP itself one nice
thing about DSP is that it gives us very
easy access to a language model so what
I'm showing in this cell 13 here is a
direct call to the language model with
the string which U.S states border no
U.S states and you can see it's given me
a list of responses and kind of
messiness with all their new lines here
you can add in keyword parameters to the
underlying language model if that model
honors them and that will affect the
behavior of this function call so here
I've called it with temperature 0.9 and
I'm getting four responses back and you
can see it's listed them out in a list
there
another nice thing about DSP is that if
you call lm.inspect history it will show
you the previous calls to the language
model and it's formatted those quite
nicely so if you're uncertain about what
you're feeding into your model and that
can happen with DSP you can call inspect
history and get a look at what you
actually did
now mostly for DSP you won't call the
language model directly the way we just
did you will rely on DSP templates to
kind of format prompts to the language
model and also extract information from
the generated answer to use as kind of
the basis for your system
so here I've set up a very simple
template this happens in The Notebook QA
template it's got question and answer
components and include some instructions
and then for example if you create a DSP
example from our running case which U.S
states border no U.S states and you
called it with a sample of two Squad
training instances to use as
demonstrations
you can feed that through your template
and what you get
is something that looks like this where
our Target question is at the bottom
waiting to be answered and here are
those two demonstrations that we sampled
from the squad train set
here are the instructions and here's
some formatting stuff that comes from
the template and this is a pretty good
standard mode for all these modern large
language models to help them do in
context learning and figure out what you
want them to do based on information in
the prompt and the demonstrations you've
provided
and here to kind of put those pieces
together you have in DSP what I've
called prompt based generation so
dsp.generate you feed that through a
template and that gives you a kind of
generator function that when called on a
DSP example will give you back some
responses and here's the answer value
from the completions Alaska Hawaii is
how it has answered the question which
U.S states border no U.S states
and again if you feel unsure you can
call inspect history and you'll see
exactly what happened it looks like this
there's that prompt again with our two
sample demonstrations and there's the
generated response in green
the other part of this assignment is
thinking about retrieval and as I said
before for that we have given you a
Colbert index and a Colbert retrieval
mechanism that you can use and you can
mostly just treat that as a very
effective retrieval mechanism
here's a question that we can use it as
an example
dsp.retrieve when given a string and
some number of passages we want in
response will give you back a list of
passages that you can use for
constructing prompts and so forth
as with the language model if you need
deeper access to the retrieval mechanism
you can call it directly with RM called
on a string and that will allow you to
have a bunch of other keyword parameters
in here and give you more information
back than just the list of passages for
example scores and other things that go
along with retrieval so that's there if
you want to design more advanced systems
as part of your original system
all of these things come together in the
first part of the notebook this is a
little DSP program that is a complete
solution to few shot open QA it's just
this tiny program let's walk through it
first keep this in mind use this
decorator
dsp.transformation on all of your
programs
so that your programs don't modify the
DSP examples that come in you'll be
augmenting them with demonstrations and
maybe changing the fields and you don't
want that to have an In-Place impact on
for example the squad data set that you
have loaded in so as a precaution always
add this decorator to all your DSP
functions and your life will be more
sensible
next programs operate on DSP example
instances individual ones that's what's
coming in here keep that in mind
in the first line of this little program
we sample K random demonstrations from
the squad train set by default and K is
the user supplied parameter there that
gives us demonstrations attribute on the
example that came in
then we use our QA template as before I
decide to find that on slide 12. that
gives us this new moderator moderate
modified generator function for the
language model
right that's the modified generator we
call that on an example and we get back
completions as well as a copy of the
example DS can be completions is the
heart of this it will have an answer
attribute because of the QA template and
that's the field that we'll use as the
answer that the system has responded to
the question with
so that's the complete program for few
shot open QA and the assignment
questions essentially ask you to write
very similar programs both of the
questions are DSP programs just like
that one question one is few shot open
QA with context so a small modification
of the program I just showed you where
you add in context passages that you
retrieve using Colbert
and then question two asks you to use
the annotate primitive from DSP which is
very powerful as a mechanism for doing
lots of things and what we have you use
it to do is construct demonstrations
that will be especially effective for
guiding the system toward the behaviors
that you want it to have in context
and that having done those things you
design your original system we expect
your original system to be a DSP program
because we think you we've provided you
lots of Primitives for writing really
powerful DSP programs that will be
really interesting solutions to the
problems we've posed but it is not
required as before original systems can
take many forms and you should feel free
to use whatever techniques you would
like
if you would like to explore DSP even
further Omar has created intro an intro
notebook that walks through additional
Advanced programs for really hard QA
problems we're going to talk about a
bunch of those techniques when we talk
about in context learning a lot of the
most powerful ones are exemplified in
that intro notebook where we show you
how we have DSP Primitives that make it
very easy to make use of those Concepts
so that's a powerful Next Step that you
might check out as part of thinking
about your original system